And did you become involved with certain,
so that would be,
I started doing particle physics in 95 and when was,
when did the large Hadron collider go live?
That was,
um,
I remember it was 2000 and
2007 I think it was a 2008.
It's so long ago.
I was about 10 years ago.
But he started up,
we started up and then we had a problem with it and then it took a while to fix.
Um,
so has it been taking data that long?
But it's a tremendously successful thing now and it's,
it's operating beyond its design capabilities.
It's quite incredible.
It's so stunning.
Is the thing that this,
I mean,
how large is it?
How large?
The largest,
he said he's 27 kilometers,
so I'd say about 16 miles.
16 miles.
And it's a circular.
Yeah.
Sort of a building.
Well you see it's a big tube.
And when you think basically it's mo mainly under France and partly into
Switzerland.
And he accelerates protons around in a circle.
Now both ways.
They won't.
One beam goes,
well,
my one goes the other way.
And they go round 11,000 times a second cause that's the very close,
the speed of light in 99.999999% the speed of light.
And then we crossed the beams and collide the particles.
And in there's collisions,
you're recreating the conditions that were present less than a billionth of a
second after the big bang.
So we know that physics,
so going back when you said about the carbon and the oxygen,
we can trace that story back way beyond the time when they were protons and
neutrons to when they were quarks and gluons around and then go all the way back
and the Higgs Boson doing its thing back then so we can see all that physics in
the lab.
So that's why we have some,
a lot of confidence in that story.
It's so fascinating that they were able to talk someone into funding that,
that they got a bunch of people together and that you,
you were able to explain to politicians and,
and you know,
regular people what you're trying to do.
It's a great example of how you get something done.
So it was the night,
the 50s when certain was established,
I think it was 53 or 54,
can't quite remember.
It's something like that.
And then it was bill from the Second World War,
so say,
yeah,
you're up at the end of the war.
And it was realized that the only way forward for your,
it was collaboration to rebuild the scientific base and in for peace for
peaceful purposes.
And so cern was set up as an international collaboration in Europe initially
with that political ideal that it would,
it would explore nature,
uh,
just for,
for freely and for peace,
for peaceful means and peaceful reasons.
And so that was,
uh,
the Poli,
the politics was right.
So we set it by international treaty so that the men,
the states are bound together by treaty and they pay a small man relatively
small amount each into cern every year,
which is a percentage of their GDP.
And that's the money they used to build the experiments and build the
accelerators.
So it's very hard to get out of it.
And you wouldn't really want to because it's a small amount of money per country
and certain doesn't get extra money to build things.
It just takes his money and basically saves up and plans itself.
But because it's got a regular stream of money,
it can do it.
They can say,
we're going to build this machine and it will take eight years because that's
how much money we've got.
Now we're building in eight years and we know how much money we've got so we can
do it.
You know,
it's the lesson.
I mean the reason that the u s collider,
the SSC failed is because it's the problem you have in the us with the funding
system as you've seen in the last few weeks,
is that it's very arbitrary and it's open to political maneuvering and things
can be shut down and take an answer.
And he's not like that.
Cerner has got a guaranteed stream of funding small from each country,
and so you can do these projects.
And the one in the u s that was during the Clinton administration as I would,
it was a,
yeah,
it was closed.
Was it Clinton here?
It was closed down for by Congress on a very slim vote and it was,
it was in Texas,
so it was,
it was one of those things where you've got states vying for money and he was
half built and everyone was there,
you know,
and the thing,
it was bigger than the LHC and it was closed down.
So you waste a lot of money.
Is that a huge disappointment for scientific community?
Like where people are very hopeful that this was going to go alarm,
it was being built.
So it Doug,
half the tunnel.
What would it be able to do that the LHC couldn't,
it was a higher energy accelerated than the LHC.
So it would have discovered the Higgs particle first.
Uh,
had it been running,
but the,
the half bill part,
is it useless now or can they I think sort of filled the,
charge it up again now.
I think they filled it in.
I think so.
I mean it was just half a tunnel,
you know?
That's the thing,
it,
you can do these wonderful things for not a lot of money if you just do it over
many years now.
Stable funding and just commit to doing it.
The filling and end part hustler and you look at certain as well and people,
yeah,
people ask me now,
I think the UK pays a bow.
It's about a hundred million dollars a year.
That's what the UK pays in and it's that same for Germany.
Same for France and so on.
And some people say,
what do we get for that?
I mean,
first of all,
it's not,
the whole budget of cern is about the same as a budget of a medium sized
university.
So it's not a lot.
It's about a billion dollars a year or something,
which is what a university has.
So it's not a lot in the scheme of things.
What's it done though?
While we invented the World Wide Web,
as we've just said,
a lot of the medical imaging technology that we use comes from cern and has
pioneered the use of these very high field magnets,
which is what it needed.
So it's,
it's engineering at the edge and engineering at the edge,
uh,
generates spinoffs and expertise to get used in other fields.
So as cancer treatments,
so called had Ron beam therapy.
So you got a brain tumor.
Now it's quite likely that you'll have one of these targeted particle beam
therapists,
which is like very highly targeted sort of chemotherapy.
It's not chemotherapy,
it's just radiation that you can target in a beam into your head and attack the
tumor.
And those,
those are particle accelerators.
So most particle accelerators today are in hospitals and in medicine,
but they came from doing particle physics that,
so the,
the,
the spin offs of these big experiments at the edge of our capability are always
immense,
which is why they're worth funding at these very low levels.
But it's not just the knowledge,
it's the engineering expertise that there is a practical application for every,
every day.
They're always,
it's just finding out how to do hard things is usually useful.